voilà un bien étrange saint georges
terrassant le dragon parce que si on
voit saint georges
on se demande bien où elle dragon
pour cause c'était initialement un
tableau en deux panneaux dont il ne
reste que la partie de gauche au xviiie
siècle le tableau se trouve dans la
collection d'un ministre allemand qui le
montre à tout le monde comme un portrait
la grande héroïne française
si bien que fredrik von schiller en 1801
lorsqu'il décrit sa grande pièce à
succès jeanne d'arc mais qui peut être
traduit dans toutes les langues et va
être vraiment le modèle pour représenter
jeanne d'arc va se rendre pour voir le
tableau et le copier exactement
[Musique]
l'armure être copié fidèlement son
personnage va porter exactement avec
costumes et ce tableau va connaître
grandes célébrités puisqu'il sera
considérée vraiment comme la référence
pour représenter jeanne d'arc alors les
traits un peu androgyne cette armure qui
en est fait et du 15e siècle ont fait
croire que c'était jeanne d'arc
jusqu'à une date avancée puisque au
milieu du 19e siècle on off n'offrent
triomphalement ce portrait aux
collections de la maison jeanne d'arc à
orléans qu'elle ne suit pas la déception
de la vie trente ans plus tard on
réalise ac
certes il s'agissait d'un tableau du 15e
siècle et qui représentait pas du tout
jeanne d'arc mais bien saint georges
sans son dragon
[Musique]